after weeks of dismal news for democrats
from the courts
from the economy and most of all from
public opinion polls the american left
has decided that the best way to turn
their bad luck around and salvage the
midterm elections
is to put a transvestite bureaucrat on
television to demand that parents trans
their little kids
gender affirming care is life saving
medically necessary
age appropriate and a critical tool for
health care providers
as a pediatrician when it comes to
making sure kids are healthy and happy
i know how important care that affirmed
someone's true identity can be
i feel sorry for richard levine that guy
i'm not being facetious when i say that
i truly feel sorry for him he is
obviously a tortured and extremely
confused man and he is being encouraged
by powerful people in his delusions
until recently
i felt sorry for mr levine in the same
way that i feel sorry for all sick
people
pure pity
recently that has begun to change
i still feel sorry for him but i am
beginning to feel sorry for him in the
way that i feel sorry for a criminal
i feel genuine sorrow for criminals even
though they do evil things i feel sorry
for criminals precisely because they do
evil things because they are harming
themselves and others and leading bad
lives
but i also want to stop them from doing
what they are doing because they are
hurting other people too
richard levine is now pretty clearly
hurting other people he is using his
position of authority in the federal
government
to encourage parents to sterilize their
little kids and mutilate their bodies
and give them all sorts of irreversible
injuries just so that he can validate
his own disordered sexual desires and
delusions he is encouraging innocent
little kids to be permanently disfigured
into ghastly caricatures because he
doesn't want to accept reality a sane
society would put this man in counseling
an upside down culture puts him in a
dress and makes him the assistant
secretary for health i'm michael knowles
this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from voyage to the
inner mind
who says there was an article explaining
that because abortion is becoming
illegal it will decimate the pickup
hookup culture
my response that's perfect another win
that's true that's that's called an
added benefit you know what that's
really called that's called culture is
downstream of politics
we all say politics is downstream of
culture there's some truth to that
what we're seeing now is culture being
downstream of politics the court makes a
decision the congress passes a law the
government does something and then new
and improved perhaps cultural behaviors
follow good stuff we gotta love it we
want people to do the right thing and to
be able to flourish and lead good lives
when you want good people to help you
flourish you got to check out
ziprecruiter right now go to
ziprecruiter.com
knowles tri-zip recruiter for free
summer is upon us we're all traveling
think about
what makes for a great trip you've got
the hotel concierge you've got the
waiter at the restaurant you got that
bartender that you befriend you know
that outstanding talent is crucial for a
successful business well if you're
hiring you can find talent for roles
such as those and others at ziprecruiter
when you try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com
knowles
zip recruiter uses powerful matching
technology to find and match the right
candidates up with your job then you
easily review those recommended
candidates you invite your top choices
to apply they've got a complete suite of
tools that makes it easy to filter
review and rate your candidates you know
time is money it's really really
important to get the top candidates and
to do it fast that's why ziprecruiter is
the number one rated hiring site
according to g2 satisfaction ratings as
of january 1st of this year so travel to
this easy to remember destination
zipruder.com knowles that's where you
can try zip recruiter for free
ziprecruiter.com
k-w-l-e-s zip recruiter the smartest way
to hire
in an upside-down culture
falsehood is called truth
and evil is called goodness and ugliness
is called beauty that's what happens and
we we always focus on the first two we
focus on now how
the left tells us that lies are the
truth and the truth is lies we focus on
how the left inverts the moral order and
says that bad things are good things and
good things are bad things
just as important though and frankly
even more manifest more obvious to our
senses is that last part the fact that
in an upside down disordered culture the
culture begins to worship ugliness
begins to shun beautiful things and
worship ugliness and that is what is
going on in our culture right now
i actually proved the point
sort of inadvertently yesterday
i i was
reading some article online and a
picture by picasso popped up it was the
the picture the weeping woman from 1937
and it's one of those
sort of
first thing your mind goes to picasso
paintings where it's all weird angles
and shapes and cubes and all this kind
of weird jumbly stuff and
i remembered that picasso was an amazing
painter he actually was an amazing
incredible painter who could paint real
great works of beauty but he did all the
really beautiful paintings very early in
his life
there's one painting in particular it's
called science and charity that he
painted
40 years prior so i think
1897 1896 1897 he was he was 15 or 16
years old and he painted this this
pretty beautiful painting and i asked
this question on twitter i said
why would a painter who can paint
a beautiful painting
choose to paint an ugly painting
why and it was just a modest question
about the development of american art or
i'm sorry the development of western art
broadly though we see this in particular
in america
and the libs lost their mind
the libs
lost their mind i am still getting
notifications of angry blue check libs
screaming at me calling me a nazi
saying that this is
i'm an idiot uncultured this is just the
worst
vituperation i have seen in response to
any tweet
it was a simple question
why would someone who can paint
beautiful art paint uglier and they lost
their minds and
i did have a little bit of a suspicion
that they might lose their minds
because it's not merely that the left
has a slight preference for ugly stuff
over beautiful stuff it's not merely
that the left likes kind of weird modern
art over traditional beautiful art it's
that the left
worships ugliness
they shun beautiful things and they
exalt
ugly things it is a cult
of ugliness
you see this everywhere throughout the
culture you see this in left-wing
fashion
left-wing fashion is get rid of
beautiful stuff
wear ugly weird disordered stuff you see
this in the way that people treat their
bodies
when you see leftists protesting having
a mostly peaceful protest do they
usually have their hair done very nicely
but put on a little bit of lipstick
no usually they're mutilated and they've
got all sorts of
piercings in places that they shouldn't
be and all sorts of
excessive tattoos everywhere insane hair
and they it's it's an intentional
disfigurement it's an intentional
mutilation of of what could be beautiful
you see this in left-wing art obviously
you see this in left-wing architecture
the radical modern architecture it's
never beautiful it's always just weird
it's weird and ugly and disfigured
why is that
why is that it's b it's because these
things go together because goodness
truth and beauty go together they're the
transcendentals okay if you if you're
attracted to one if you like one and
you're pursuing one you're probably
going to pursue the other two as well
and the inverse is also true if you're
living in a lies in a life and in a
culture
mired in lies
and an inversion of the moral order it's
also going to be ugly too you see it in
advertising now especially in
left-wing advertising they've gotten rid
of all the beautiful models and they
replace them with ugly models
intentionally ugly models
you see this you see this throughout the
culture
and if you call them out for it they
call you a nazi
they call and sir the argument for for
this is they say well the nazis also
didn't like bad art
you say well okay i mean stalin didn't
like bad art he was a communist and uh
actually the guy who wrote the book on
this very question who shunned the the
crappy modern art and liked good
beautiful traditional art is max nordau
who is not only not a nazi but he was a
jew not only was he a jew but he was one
of the leaders of world wide global
zionism so i don't think is that guy a
nazi no well but
but some nazis said well hitler drank
water no we're making a point about art
here
and the very fact that people re that
the left reacts in this way two
beautiful things they tear down
beautiful statues
they they close up beautiful works of
art
and they replace it with ugliness it's
not good it's just it's just a good
signpost to know okay we're dealing with
a radical leftist inverted culture
you take men who might look perfectly
fine as men you dress them up as
caricatures of women not real women but
caricatures think of drag queens okay
and vice versa now speaking of stupid
art i saw the dumbest political cartoon
i think i've ever seen in my whole life
in the washington post
this was a cartoon by anne
telnays
and it was based on this supreme court
decision in kennedy versus bremerton
school district that just came out this
is about the coach praying privately on
the field after the game
and said if you're okay with this
that's the coach praying to god on the
50-yard line you should be okay with
this and it was a pentagram surrounded
by candles in some sort of black mass on
the high school football field
to which i would respond
uh no you shouldn't
no there those are not the same
having a private prayer to god is not
the same as having a satanic ritual on a
football field and the reason they're
not the same is not even just procedural
it's because
god and the devil are different
those are different things
if you pray to god right you you it does
not necessarily follow that you uh would
support worshipping the devil actually
the opposite would follow
because it's not merely the form of
things that matters but it's the content
of things that matters too
and actually if we have a culture that
does worship god
then a lot of other things are going to
follow
we're going to
support a more traditional moral order
more traditional behavior more
traditional standards of beauty and
decency and behavior
those things are all going to follow
it's not it's not merely the opposite
it's not anything goes
okay this
you you can't you can't simultaneously
have all of these things you can't have
a culture that worships god and the
devil simultaneously you can't have a
culture that says that a man is a man
and a culture that says a man is a woman
simultaneously you can't have a culture
that does opposite things simultaneously
you've got to make a decision the
question is what what kind of culture do
you want to be you want to be the
beautiful culture or do you want to be
the ugly disordered disfigured culture
me if you ask me i want the former but
we can talk about it when you want to
talk about it we got to go check out
puretalk right now go to peertalk.com
enter promo code knowles podcast i love
pure talk for multiple reasons one i
have pure talk i'm a pure talk customer
i love my phone i love my service it is
the top rated service in the country so
it's absolutely fabulous you're not
gonna drop calls you're not gonna miss
messages things like that
but the other reason that i absolutely
love pure talk is that they support the
voicemail back on this show these guys
are the reason that i get to hear from
you in the voice mail bag and so you've
got to go switch right now you're
getting pinched right now the economy is
in shambles and you're still probably
paying 80 bucks a month maybe more 90
bucks a month for your cell service
don't do that you can get all the talk
you want all the text you want and
plenty of data for 30 bucks a month no
price increases there no nothing okay
and you get an extremely
strong 5g network it's just great go to
puretalk.com select a plan enter promo
code knowles podcast
you can actually save 50
off your first month right now switching
over to pure talk takes less than 10
minutes i'm not joking less than 10
minutes enter code knowles podcast
k-w-l-e-s-p-o-d-c-a-s-t
all one word at puretalk.com
speaking of god and providence there's
one last little coda to the dobbs story
the the decision that overruled roe v
wade that i have to get to i mentioned
that there were some strange
coincidences on the day of the dobb's
decision
the day the decision came down to end
the quote-unquote constitutional right
to abortion after
49 years that will save hundreds of
thousands of babies per year and give a
path to potentially abolishing abortion
throughout the country the day that that
happened was the feast of the sacred
heart of jesus
now if you're a christian you might say
wow that's quite a coincidence
the day that that happened also
traditionally the feast of the nativity
of saint john the baptist who in the
gospel
leaps in his mother's womb when christ
in his mother's womb approaches him
this is one of the clearest
gospel examples of
the prohibition against abortion do you
see the the little baby little baby john
the baptist is leaping in the mother's
room and dancing because his savior also
a little fetus is is
near him
that's that's quite a coincidence too
and then i saw on cnn the night before
there was a report
that that on the 24th on the day of the
dobbs decision there was going to be a
rare alignment of five planets the stars
the planets are aligning on this
particular day i said wow that's kind of
a weird coincidence and then a listener
pointed this out to me
in the article
in the article on space.com of with the
photo that everyone is posting about
this planet alignment
the the photograph was taken by
right
dobbs
just a little i'm not i'm not asking you
to follow me like a beautiful mind and
i'm making all the connections here on
some whiteboard or something
just pointing out that's
that's quite a coincidence that's a nice
little coincidence my priest who wrote a
book on coincidence his father george
rutler he pointed out that it's a it's
an evil generation that looks for signs
and wonders but it's a stupid generation
that ignores signs and wonders and
sometimes you see these little signs
these little coincidences in your life
and i consider them i don't look always
for the deeper meaning and what does
this mean and what does this mean for
how i should behave tomorrow and i i
just look at it as a little wink of
providence
a little wink of oh hey don't forget
there's an order here
there is a logic to the universe
things are unfolding in a way that has
logic to it
so just a nice little wink it makes you
it gives one comfort
not because it it tells you how to
predict the future
not supposed to do that not because it
gives you some secret leg up on the
other people who don't know how to
interpret the signs it's not that's not
what it's about
it's just to remind you
there is a god there is an order there
is providence that's a good thing that's
a good that's that's a
that's a nice little consolation to have
in the world
speaking of the dobbs decision
msnbc is still rending its garments and
gnashing its teeth over the dobbs
decision and now they're beginning to
set the stage for attacks on the supreme
court you've got joe scarborough who is
the fake republican one of the fake
republicans on msnbc though these days i
don't know if he would even call himself
a republican he was a republican
congressman many moons ago and now he's
a liberal commentator on msnbc
he went so far as to say that the dobbs
decision constitutes violence
it wasn't just the holding
taking away a fundamental right over the
past 50 years they found the tone to be
confrontational and anyone who has
followed the supreme court anyone who
has read constitutional law
knows that most justices especially in
landmark decisions bend over backwards
to explain how this is not a radical
move this is this is we are moving
forward and we're moving in the
direction uh that this country's been
moving in and we understand their
problems but this is and they'll round
off some of the harsher edges they will
give something to their opponents uh
their their their legal or ideological
opponents there was none of that there i
i've got to say
more than any supreme court decision
i've ever read
it it
it was
even the language there was a violence
to the reasoning we win
you lose yeah we're taking away these
rights and there's nothing you can do
about it
what is joe scarborough talking about
forget what he's saying about dobbs for
a second just historically i i don't
know what he's talking about he's saying
that in landmark decisions that can
reverse major other decisions usually
they're really modest and moderate and
gracious and find some middle ground
what are you talking about
think about brown versus board of
education
granville board of education reverses
plessy v ferguson and
says no separate but equal is it's not
it's not really going to work it's not
actually equal and so we're going to get
rid of it this is a decision that
everybody supports now does does
joe scarborough believed that that
should have been a more modest decision
well maybe maybe we're only going to
integrate some bathrooms
well maybe
listen we're going to integrate some
water fountains but not others because
we're going to be really great no of
course nobody would suggest that that
would be insane
if it's a landmark decision you are
making a claim
you are making a big claim and it's
going to have big effects how about some
of the bad decisions
about some how about roe v wade was roe
v wade was certainly a landmark decision
was that really gracious and soft and
conciliatory to the other side no it
resulted in the deaths of hundreds of
thousands of babies a year immediately
and pretend that there's a
constitutional right to an abortion when
there isn't one
that if there's ever a violent decision
that's the one that's the most violent
decision ever in the history of
the judiciary
how about obergefell
obergefell which redefines marriage for
the first time in human history away
from what it had broadly always been
into something completely different was
that a conciliatory modest gracious
decision of course not
that was a spiking the football for
goodness sakes anthony kennedy in that
said that at the heart of liberty lies a
right to intimacy a right to intimacy
and then he starts waxing poetic about
how marriage really when you really
think about it you know isn't what
people always thought it was but it's
actually a union between two dudes and
two chicks as well
because i don't know because that's what
anthony kennedy thinks do you think that
was conciliatory no of course not
of course not
and in this case this decision was not
particularly conciliatory either because
it was saying look there's
there is no constitutional right to an
abortion and there's no way to pardon
the phrase split the baby here okay
either there is a constitutional right
to an abortion or there isn't there
isn't one therefore it's going back to
the states it's going back to the people
and you guys can deal with it fairly
conciliatory in the sense that the
people get to make their own decisions
in california if they want to have 17th
trimester abortions that i guess they
can have them now at least for the time
being
but no there's no middle ground here and
and
joe scarborough and the rest of the
liberals are just really upset that the
court is is not going to enshrine some
fake right to kill babies anymore and so
he calls it violent
he calls not killing babies violent
and he is calling it violent to justify
attacks on the court it's the same
reason that the left calls language that
they don't like violent they say when a
conservative shows up to a college
campus that constitutes an act of
violence the reason they say that is to
justify their own actual acts of
violence their own physical violence on
the speakers which happens
with regularity it's happened to me it's
happened to
a great number of other conservative
speakers on college campuses speaking of
dumb
takes on the dobbs decision
have to get to whoopi goldberg's whoopi
goldberg on the view discussing
uh clarence thomas's concurrence which
i'm sure she hasn't read to the majority
opinion which again i'm sure she hasn't
read for the case that i'm sure she
doesn't understand
and why clarence thomas was so dumb
to side with the conservatives
well you better hope that they don't
come for you clarence and say you should
not be married to your wife who happens
to be white
because they will move back and you
better hope that nobody says you know
well you're not in the constitution
you're back to being a quarterback
that's not gonna work either
what
what does any of that mean first of all
she says she says clarence clarence you
better hope that they don't come after
you next
who is they here
that they to whom you are referring
is clarence thomas clarence thomas is
the one who knocks okay
clarence thomas is the one who issues
these decisions
and no no one's coming after clarence
thomas you're going to try to get him to
divorce his wife other than the libs
because the libs hate his wife jenny
because she's an effective conservative
activist and then she says what now
pretty soon
they're going to make you a quarter of a
person again
are you is
is whoopi referring to the
three-fifths compromise not the quarter
of a person the three-fifths compromise
in the constitution that said for
purposes of representation in the
federal government
enslaved portions of the population will
be counted by three-fifths
is that
does she understand even what that was
it doesn't mean that black people were
three-fifths
of a person
actually it was the slave states that
wanted to count the black people as
whole people
and it was the free states that wanted
to count black people as no people not
because the slave states really liked
the black people and the free states
didn't like the black people but sort of
the opposite in many ways because the
slave states wanted greater
representation in the federal government
in part because it wouldn't shrink
slavery and the free states didn't want
that
that we could go on and on the the
misunderstanding of the three-fifths
compromise or in whoopi's words the
one-quarter compromise is is one of the
most irksome and frivolous
aspects of ignorance in in our culture
today but
the real issue here i mean one this is
why the left attacked civics class but
but two
american self-government is not
possible it's nearly impossible with
this level of ignorance among the elite
not even among the people broadly but
among the elite whoopi goldberg is on
television on a network
public affairs show on a show where
where they discuss political issues
almost exclusively in an ignorant way in
a destructive way but the fact that she
doesn't
have
any idea what she's talking about even
about the most basic aspects of the
constitution
is a real threat because if this is the
basis for our political discourse then
we're not even speaking language anymore
we're not not only is it sort of ugly
and a little bit a little bit off-kilter
it's completely incoherent if it's
incoherent we can't govern ourselves you
know we could not
wait until the 4th of july we could not
so we are lighting the fireworks early
with backstage live at the ryman
auditorium in nashville tennessee
nashville tennessee usa baby you can
catch the show in all its glory on our
live stream at 8 p.m eastern tonight go
to
dailywire.com
knowles k-n-o-w-l-e-s
canada w-l-e-s save a huge amount of
money i'm not even going to tell you how
much save a lot of money when you
subscribe today
dailywire.com knowles here's a look at
last year's event
welcome to the daily wire backstage live
at the famous ryman auditorium
it was amazing we were in the presence
of greatness the energy of having
everyone on the same page was amazing if
your family member is still waiting for
fauci to give them permission to leave
their house it might be time to cut that
off
i'm actually pretty excited to meet all
of them i love everybody's opinion
individually i don't have a favorite i
like them all i had found out a way to
make football players cry in high school
my high school experience
i'm just excited to be here and be
surrounded by like-minded people
and to just you know feel that energy
who should we remove from office one
politician the most powerful politician
in the country dr fauci
we're doing culture here i'm so thrilled
to see this happening if they say to
half of the country you can't that half
of the country needs to say screw you we
will
we hope that you will be able to join us
today and and help us to fight this
battle more than we already have you
know we've gotten a ton of wins recently
so make sure that uh you tune in and
continue that fight we got a lot more
stuff planned dailywire.com knowles yet
okay i'll tell you it's 25 off your new
membership as exciting as the last year
has been we are just getting started
tune in tonight live at the ryman find
out what is next 8 pm eastern you can
watch it at
dailywire.com you can watch it at
dailywire.com ryman you can subscribe at
dailywire.com
knowles we'll see you there
welcome back to the show speaking of our
elite
elaine maxwell
the business associate paramour and
madam for jeffrey epstein
has just been sentenced to 20 years in
prison but i got to tell you what
something tells me she's not going to
serve her entire term
her entire sentence
no
i i don't think that elaine maxwell is
going to be in prison for 20 years i
think she's probably
i think it's going to be shorter and i
don't think it's going to be shorter
because of parole unless parole is the
new nickname that we're giving to
hillary clinton i don't think so
i think that
you know you're going to see a fedex
truck pull up
you're going to see some kind of shadowy
figure
in a nice purple pantsuit
with groucho glasses on and a big thick
moustache
walking in there kind of bulging at the
hips
and then the cameras are going to go out
and then the guards are going to fall
asleep
and then it's just me and you elaine
that's that's that's right it's old hill
dog again
you thought you were through with me
elaine i don't think so uh no hillary no
please hillary i'll do anything that's
no i'm
i'm possibly joking i'm not quite sure
but i don't think she's going to serve
her whole term
they already put her on suicide watch
even though her attorney says she is not
suicidal another psychologist who
examined her said she is not suicidal uh
that's that's ominous that they would
put her on suicide watch already maybe
she makes it i don't know that she'll be
assassinated or kill herself or whatever
uh but
the entire process has been really
really weird all the way back to the
first prosecution and investigation of
jeffrey epstein where he got this
ridiculous sweetheart deal down in palm
beach because the u.s attorney heard
from his higher-ups that epstein
belonged to intelligence that's the
that's the testimony of alex acosta when
he was up for labor secretary but he had
been u.s attorney down there in florida
then
epstein basically was just checking in
at the at the county jail in palm beach
and then he was going about living his
life perfectly fine
then he finally there was too much of a
media storm he does get arrested and he
winds up dead in prison because just all
those cameras malfunction and the lights
and the guards and whoopsie-daisy what
what can you say that's too bad these
people who have the
uh blackmail and the extremist form of
blackmail on
the most powerful people in the world
then all of a sudden you get the arrest
of kelane maxwell and yet we haven't
seen very much from the trial we haven't
heard very much from the trial and most
importantly
we don't know who's in the book
that's all i care about i don't care if
elaine maxwell serves her sentence i
don't i don't really care about elaine
maxwell at all i don't really care about
jeffrey epstein at all i want to know
about the operation
i want to know who was funding the
operation jeffrey epstein had a lot of
money and no one really seems able to to
explain where the money came from
were there other backers were there
other private backers were there state
backers what does it mean that he
belonged to intelligence that's kind of
weird
and then here's what i really want to
know before gulen puts on the orange
jumpsuit and waits for hillary to come
and knock it
who's in the book who's in the book
who are the clients
who went who was going to the island
what did they do when did they go how
many times were they on the airplane
that's what i want to know and yet
that's the only information we can't
seem to find and everybody seems in on
it
the federal investigators the
prosecutors the everybody seemed the
media for that matter
why don't we know who is in that book we
got her we got her she's in the orange
jumpsuit she's just been sentenced
why are they closing the book why is
there some sweetheart deal here that
keeps all of these clients
out of the media spotlight
it it the reason i'm making some jokes
about hillary clinton here the reason
that people are making those jokes and
not jokes is because we don't have any
trust in the elite because this case in
particular and so many others are so
obviously crooked and corrupt that's why
because we don't think that we can
believe the federal government
we don't think that we can believe the
justice system we don't we don't have
any respect for these shadowy elites and
not so shadowy elites fairly public
figures who were shown up to the island
getting weird massages from the little
girls
that's why
and this is what because we don't have
respect for these institutions anymore
because they've squandered their
credibility
we're all expecting elaine maxwell to to
be suicided
how many of you out that you're thinking
right now here listening to this show
if elaine maxwell turned up dead
tomorrow one would you be surprised too
do you think she would have killed
herself
i bet the majority of people would say
yeah she might turn up dead and no i
don't think it would i think she would
be assassinated
there was the weird death of john mcafee
the eccentric libertarian
gazillionaire behind the software
bearing his own name remember he said
i'm not i'm not suicidal i'm not going
to kill myself people are trying to kill
me i might wind up dead in a prison and
what happened he wound up dead in a
prison he even had a tattoo that said
whacked
jeffrey epstein no one thinks that
jeffrey epstein killed himself very few
people do
why do we think this stuff happens
there have been weird cases there's one
case i don't know if you've seen this
it's gotten a little bit of reporting in
the mainstream media but it's a strange
one the case of michael hastings you
ever hear about this one this was a few
years ago now
michael hastings was a journalist who
was working on some stories about the
deep state about the alphabet letter
agencies and the
secret workings of the federal
government at home and abroad and he
began to think that he was being tracked
and he began to think that he was being
surveilled and he began to think that
people were coming after him
and then he wound up dead of a really
weird car crash
and it
the this car crash didn't just raise the
eyebrows of the tin foil hat conspiracy
theorist cooks raised the eyebrows of
very well respected and credentialed
national security officials the former
u.s national coordinator for security
infrastructure protection and
counterterrorism richard clark
said that what is known about the crash
is quote consistent with a car cyber
attack he was quoted as saying
there is reason to believe that
intelligence agencies for major powers
including the united states know how to
remotely seize control of a car so if
there were a cyber attack on hastings
car i'm not saying there was i think
whoever did it would probably get away
with it
that's kind of spooky stuff that the
governments could do that and that
people believe that they would have done
that now other people around this
journalist michael hastings said well he
was being erratic he was he had other
problems i don't know maybe he did just
kill himself and maybe he did i don't
know i don't i don't know very much
about this case at all
that's actually sort of the whether he
was assassinated or not is almost beside
the point
the the
the more important point for all of us
is the erosion of trust that we have in
our established institutions
we think that these these institutions
could do these kinds of things and so we
allowed jeffrey epstein died okay well
he didn't kill himself oh elaine
maxwell's on suicide watch here we go
set your clocks here we go
that that speaks to a corrupt elite
an elite that is now
so mired in lies
and
wickedness
and ugliness and all the stuff that we
don't want in society that the society
has become unrecognizable and they wield
a lot of power you want to talk about
corrupt elites
there are two really great attorneys
really good
top quality attorneys who just won a
major victory for the second amendment
at the supreme court i'm talking about
the new york state rifle and pistol
association the bruin case the case that
said that new yorkers do in fact have a
right to keep and bear arms so they go
up there they make the case to the
supreme court and they win
this is a landmark victory
in a well-ordered just good society
these guys would get a promotion the the
lawyers paul clement and aaron murphy
would have corner offices
right now bigger even bigger better
offices they'd probably get a little
bonus what actually happened they both
got fired
they both got fired from their law firm
i think they were kirkland and ellis
because the firm came to them and said
hey
yeah you can't be defending the second
amendment that's very politically
incorrect so oh that's great that's cool
that you're winning this case
uh that's great wow what a big victory
for the constitution and you're going to
go down in history because of this but
yeah you got to pack up your desks here
are your couple boxes pack up your desks
get out of here you're
done which makes me think dw should
really hire these people you know new
in-house counsel paul clement yes here
we go baby we we uncanceled gina carano
we're going to uncancel paul we're going
to un-cancel erin that's right we're
going gonna we're gonna have supreme
court litigators who win historic cases
we're gonna have them as our in-house
counsel i i wish i don't i don't i think
probably
these two lawyers have other things
going on they'll probably just start
their own practice but it would be funny
it would be great i would really really
enjoy that speaking of losing jobs
the washington post
uh abortion reporter is reporting on a
proposal from elizabeth warren elizabeth
warren is very concerned that planned
parenthood employees are going to lose
their jobs because now there is no
recognized constitutional right to an
abortion there never was a right to an
abortion but it's not even recognized
anymore and so these planned parenthoods
are probably going to have to close down
liz warren suggests opening up planned
parenthoods
in national parks
you know you're walking through
yellowstone or something
and you use you know you see a nice
little old saloon and then the old
abortion mill right next to it in a log
cabin
she says they could put up tents have
trained personnel
be there to help people who need it it's
time to declare a national
emergency national emergency not enough
babies are being killed this is an
emergency if we don't declare an
emergency soon some of them might be
born so okay gosh what'll we do well the
states a lot of states don't want
abortion and abortion is not protected
by the constitution obviously and so
okay let's take over the parks let's
take over anything anything to kill the
babies this woman
you'll recall when that supreme court
decision for dobbs leaked
she
lost her mind held an impromptu press
conference walking to her car with the
fire of a thousand sons burning behind
her eyes
i am angry angry
angry and upset and determined the
united states congress can keep rovers
to sway the law of the land they just
need to do it i've never seen you so
angry you seem to be this is what
the republicans have been working toward
this day for decades they have been out
there plotting
carefully cultivating these supreme
court justices so they could have a
majority on the bench who would
accomplish something that the majority
of americans do not want
69 percent of people across this country
across this country red states and blue
states old people and young people want
roe versus wade to maintain this number
two and we
need to know
we have a right dismembering 3 000
children
we need to kill the babies
she seems so
unhinged in this video
this is an issue that is not the top
priority
for the vast majority of americans just
fifteen percent of americans consider
abortion to be the top priority
and yet the dems for some and by the way
for that fifteen percent of americans
half of them are pro-life
right half
seven and a half percent roughly those
americans who consider it the top
priority
are pro-lifers who want to get rid of
abortion around the country so we're
talking about seven eight percent of
americans
consider killing babies
and and the the desire to kill babies to
be the top priority
and yet liz warren doesn't get this
animated on the economy she doesn't get
this animated on energy she doesn't get
this animated on national security she
gets disanimated only on abortion it's
demonic
just call it like it is
it seems demonic i'm not saying the
woman is actually possessed by demons i
don't know i'm not it's beyond my pay
grade but she certainly seems like it in
that video we have to it's an emergency
i know they're gonna take my babies from
here
i've got to get them before they get
away and live
it's really really
weird and evil
and ugly it's ugly i'm not saying
elizabeth warren is an ugly woman
physically i don't think she is
necessarily she has those high
cheekbones that she pointed to to prove
that she's a native american
she's not a physically ugly woman
necessarily but she becomes very ugly
when she descends into this craziness
and radicalism it's true of all of these
protesters i mean it ties right back
into the point on picasso and why the
libs just lose their mind on
who cares who cares about picasso
who cares if i forget picasso for a
second who cares about
these questions of art history and the
development of art the i mean i care and
that i want to have a beautiful society
but i don't have steam coming out of my
ears the libs do the libs have steam
coming out of their ears to defend
things that are really ugly and
disordered that's the scheme because
they've got a nice ordered society that
they come into a nice flourishing
society and then radicalism leftism says
hey we're gonna
we're gonna mess everything up we're
gonna move everything around kind of
like a picasso painting we're going to
move this eyeball over here we're going
to move this ear where the ear should be
we're going to put it down on his
kneecap and we're just going to move and
jumble everything around
we're going to engage in what marx
called the ruthless criticism
of everything that exists
it's very very ugly leads to an ugly
society you see these protesters they're
covering themselves in fake blood and
they've got little baby dolls and
they're screeching and screaming you
know that lady when trump won even
beyond the abortion issue when trump won
in 2016 she's there
screaming you know and their faces
contort there was a gal who showed up to
one of our speeches years ago
and and she just started screaming and
shaking and yelling in the audience it's
very it's an it's an ugly thing
to do and if you are the one doing it if
you or if you are on the side of the
people who are doing that maybe rethink
what you're up to
morality and and uh traditional moral
maxims are a good guide here biology is
a good guide you know if if your side is
saying that men are secretly women
you're probably on the wrong side
but beauty beauty is a good guidepost
too here if you are on the side that
consistently promotes hideous things
throughout the culture
you're probably on the wrong side
speaking of
women who will never be president
unless joe biden's ticker goes in a way
i'm hoping that joe biden sticks around
but
kamala harris right now
was was asked about
the
various plans to enshrine abortion after
the supreme court gets rid of it the
white house appears to be rejecting
elizabeth warren's idea to take over
beautiful national parks and use them as
sites to make sacrifices to moloch and
ball
but they're trying to come up with other
solutions one question that kamala
harris was asked is
should federal tax dollars be used to
fund the travel of people in pro-life
states to go to states where they can
kill their children in the way that that
private companies right now are offering
an insurance policy
to pay for the travel of women who let's
say they live in tennessee but they want
to kill their baby they can fly to
california and they'll have a portion of
their travel expenses covered kamala
harris was asked if the same could be
done with taxpayer dollars
what about the idea of financial
resources
some form of voucher for travel child
care services other forms of support for
people for women seeking abortions in
states where it's not legal but they
just don't have the means to go
elsewhere i think you're asking a very
important point making a very important
point which is what are the details are
going to go into ensuring that women
have the ability to actually
travel
without impairment and we know that on
this issue women who have access to
resources will probably be far less
impacted by this decision than women who
don't have resources so this is
something that we are looking at this is
something that we are looking at here
and we're going to look at it and we're
going to and i'm so glad it was a really
great question i love great questions
and so it's really good that you ask the
question and we can look with our eyes
at it
the thing that you asked me about she
doesn't give an answer
she doesn't give an answer because
she knows there is no
federal right to an abortion and so
there is no
argument for the federal government
paying people to go get an abortion that
would appear to be over
that would appear to be a huge stretch
the libs lost this issue they're going
to try to fight it tooth and nail
they're going to try to break the rules
they're going to do everything they can
to try to
recreate some
license to kill your babies
but she's got she's got no answer for it
even even a more articulate vice
president or a member of the
administration would not have an answer
for it either
the
relatively prudent libs understand that
they have lost on this issue even even
joe biden this was
this i'll give him credit even though i
don't think he deserves total credit i
will give him credit when the dobbs
decision came down joe biden did not
call for violence and take to the
streets and get up in their faces and go
where their children sleep
joe biden said you got to remain
peaceful
i call on everyone no matter how deeply
they care about this decision
to keep all protests peaceful
peaceful peaceful peaceful no
intimidation
violence is never acceptable
threats
and tim and intimidation are not speech
we must stand against violence in any
form
regardless of your rationale
i'm glad he said this i'll give him
credit for saying this i hope it's
sincere i don't know that it's sincere
but
i always give him credit for saying it
i don't think the reason he said it is
because it's sincere i don't think joe
biden really has a ton of sincere
beliefs and he has used rhetoric that is
extraordinarily irresponsible throughout
his entire political career
don't forget when he was running for a
vice president he said that mitt romney
wants to put black people back in chains
okay this is a guy who is
called the president of the united
states a racist on tv smeared some kid
as a white supremacist with absolutely
no evidence and then the kid was
exonerated in court
this is a guy who is willing to be fast
and loose with his language so i
this is a guy whose staff members
fundraised for the blm rioters during
the the summer of love with the mostly
peaceful arson and murder okay this is a
guy who chose as a vice president a
woman who herself raised money for the
rioters so i i just don't think it's
sincere some people say well look joe
biden down at the bottom of his heart
he's actually a good guy i don't think
he's a good guy i think he's a nasty
nasty man and a political opportunist
and i actually think opportunism
explains why he made this statement
i think this is the best he can do right
now
i think this is the absolute best joe
biden can do i think this plays very
well for him i think he knows that
coming out and being old a nice uncle
joe and come on let's be peaceful folks
that's that's part of why he became
president why part of why he got the
nomination is to be a nice normal guy
that screeching and screaming and saying
burn it down doesn't play very well in
peoria particularly at this political
moment in this midterm election year so
i think he's doing it out of convenience
and opportunism
because the left has overplayed its hand
before we go
there's a story that just broke from
chris ruffo who's done a great job
covering critical race theory and some
of the
ways that the libs are trying to groom
our children
uh there's a show coming out from disney
called baymax apparently i'm not totally
familiar with it and in the new baymax
show
which is accessible to really really
little kids what four years old maybe
even younger
in the show the the robot character is
going shopping for tampons and asks the
women around him what tampons he should
use and he gets an answer from someone
who looks like a man but is obviously
not a man because he uses tampons he's a
transgender he's a woman pretending to
be a man
[Music]
excuse me which of these products would
you recommend
oh um
well
these are the tampons i usually use
thank you i prefer pads they're more
comfortable for me thank you i always
get the ones with wings thank you get
unscented and bleach free if you can
thank you yo my daughter loves these i
think these might be easier if it's our
first period these are really
environmentally friendly
and the way you know not to put too fine
a point on it but the way you know that
disney is really hitting it on the nose
here is the dude with the tampons is
wearing a transgender flag shirt this is
this is artwork that is being
intentionally peddled to really really
little kids where disney executives have
appeared on camera themselves and said
they are peddling the not so secret gay
agenda right they're they're actively
pushing this stuff on kids
it's disordered it's bizarre it's wrong
it's also
is this good art to you do you think
this is good do you think good art is
really pedantic and didactic and talks
about menstruation for little tiny
children and has weird creepy uh like
marshmallowy freaky nightmare cartoon
robots next to transgender dude chicks i
don't know i don't think that's good art
would you rather have your kid watch
this or beauty and the beast
this or snow white and the seven dwarves
i'm not saying that art shouldn't take
up challenging topics of course it
should one of my favorite painters in
history is caravaggio the guy is pretty
hardcore okay he presents very uh
difficult topics but in a way that is
beautiful ordered toward the good that
is edifying not that is creepy and
contrary to reality and pretends that
men are secretly actually women and
tries to groom the little kids
this the art
really matters here folks we can we we
definitely want to own the lives of
facts and logic we can totally do that
we definitely need to focus on arguing
from a real moral order that we can know
something about the difference between
good and evil if we don't know that we
can't have self-government but it's also
important to focus on beauty that third
transcendental there it's a good
guidepost and if we want people to be
conservative if we want people to love
their country we need to give them a
country that is lovable that is
beautiful a place where they want to be
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022 on
the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show